today we're going to talk about the 13
signs that your body is deficient in
your nutrients a deficiency of nutrients
doesn't necessarily mean that you're not
consuming this from your diet there's
other reasons why you might be deficient
one would be lacking your stomach acid
you don't have enough acid you can't
absorb minerals that well because
certain minerals need a certain pH to be
absorbed especially things like calcium
and iron
another way to be deficient is there's a
problem with your gallbladder or you
don't have a gallbladder or you're
deficient in bile so then it doesn't
matter how many fat soluble vitamins you
take like vitamin A d d k without that
bio it can't go into the body another
reason why people are deficient is they
have damage in about lining that's
called a malabsorption problem and the
surface area of your small intestine is
just not receiving nutrients maybe you
had a history of a lot of antibiotics or
some infection or you ate a lot of junk
food but that small intestine is needed
to absorb at least 90 percent of all
your nutrients another reason why you
might be deficient is that you're eating
refined carbohydrates or refined sugars
or alcohol or you're taking medication
like for example metformin will deplete
vitamin B12 and one other way you might
become deficient is stress stress will
deplete zinc be one calcium magnesium
and many other nutrients all right that
being said let's Dive Right In the first
sign I'm going to talk about is
fibrocystic breast so there's these
little cysts that are developing on the
breast or the ovary that is the classic
iodine deficiency when you're low in
iodine you don't have the buffering
function of estrogen anymore without
iodine estrogen can go too high creating
cysts and other problems I mean you can
even have cysts in the thyroid so iodine
is a really good trace mineral to help
regulate that level of estrogen and sea
kelp is one of the best sources of
iodine all right number two dry eye that
is a classic vitamin A deficiency
without vitamin A your mucous membranes
dry up and this could also occur in your
mouth you can add dry mouth or dry eyes
the best source of vitamin A comes from
animal product not planned all plants
have the precursor to the active form of
vitamin A called retinol so this
carotene has to convert to retinol to
actually have it work and unfortunately
you only really get about a three
percent conversion rate so if you're not
consuming animal products you may easily
get a vitamin A deficiency all right
next one red cheeks okay like rosacea
that is usually a digestive problem
there's an imbalance in micro Flora in
your gut and that's also creating an
imbalance of microphone on your skin but
as far as the nutrient deficiency that
would be a lack of B vitamins because
your microbes make the vitamins and B
vitamins protect the skin especially
vitamin B3 if you're deficient in B3
you're going to get all sorts of skin
problems from dermatitis to all
inflammatory conditions and it's been
acne all sorts of things but if you see
someone with red cheeks suspect that
there's something going on with their
gut and they need to take the good
probiotic or consume foods that have the
naturally occurring microbes like
sauerkraut or kimchi or even keep her
all right the next one I'm going to talk
about is a combination of three symptoms
shortness of breath
uh looking pale and fatigue this is
classic anemia but the key nutrients to
overcome anemia is iron
but also B12 and folate There's an
actual genetic condition this is another
thing I forgot to mention the very
beginning you can be deficient in a
nutrient if you have a genetic mutation
which nowadays they're testing your DNA
and they're finding all sorts of
weaknesses within your DNA and there's a
certain Gene that regulates activating
folate and b12 and if there's a problem
with that Gene you're going to be anemic
you're going to have a lot of problems
unless you take larger amounts of the
natural form of B12
as well as full length and this is a
side note you can also be anemic if you
have problems with your stomach because
you don't produce hydrochloric acid and
if you have some type of gut issue that
you just can't absorb the nutrients all
right number five
Corkscrew hairs on your skin now what is
that if you look closely sometimes you
have to have a little magnifying glass
on your skin and you see that these
little hairs are going in like little
Corkscrew shapes okay and there's
usually going to be a red dot where
that's originating from that's one of
the big symptoms of a vitamin C
deficiency now the correlate that
there's other vitamin C deficiency signs
as well like deleting gums like extreme
petite and what's interesting is the
chemistry of vitamin C is very similar
to the chemistry of glucose sugar
so if you are consuming glucose and
vitamin C at the same time
guess who's going to win this sugar not
the vitamin C and so you're going to
block the absorption of vitamin C so
people that consume a lot of sugar
usually are showing signs and then
vitamin C deficiency but just remember
the corkscrew little hairs on your skin
it's a classic vitamin C deficiency if
you're going to fix this problem I would
highly recommend not to use the
synthetic version of vitamin C aspic
acid I would use a whole vitamin C
complex that actually comes from like a
food or an herb all right number six
belly fat now this is not necessarily
just a vitamin deficiency but there is a
very common deficiency involved with
belly fat you see belly fat occurs when
the liver is fatty and you have this
spill off of fat from the liver
around the organs and your abdomen
giving you this protruding effect so one
really good way to get rid of fat off
your liver is to start taking choline
which is in the family of the B vitamins
and of course do the ketogenic diet you
can literally remove 50 of your fat off
your liver within two weeks by doing a
ketogenic diet all right so number seven
if you're craving ice okay or you see
someone chewing on ice plastic iron
deficiency they need iron realize that
there's two forms of iron you have the
iron that's very absorbable that's
called the bio of valuable iron ore iron
from Animal product and then you have
the non-hemean version of that which is
more difficult to absorb in plants like
for example spinach so if someone is
just eating plants and not eating any
animal products uh potentially they
could have an iron deficiency and they
may start chewing ice they also May
develop anemia all right number eight
scaling planking skin okay sometimes
it's like right around the nose
sometimes it may be anywhere in the face
the face could be slightly oily but
there's this scaly flaking skin classic
omega-3 fatty acid deficiency that
person needs to start consuming more
cognitive oil or fish oil and start to
avoid omega-6 fatty acids which which is
the corn oil the soil oil
all these fried foods that they serve at
restaurants all right number nine loss
of taste or loss of smell is mostly a
zinc deficiency it can also be related
to a virus destroying nerves in your
sinuses but if we're talking about
nutrition
it's going to be a zinc deficiency and
the best source of zinc is shellfish
like oysters you can also get zinc from
red meat as well as liver all right
number 10.
you have like this symmetrical skin rash
that is in the lower legs or the hands
or even a rash that looks like a
necklace this is a pellegra symptom
which is a B3 efficiency and if someone
is consuming way too much corn corn
products which actually is in a lot of
foods corn chips and tortillas and even
high fructose corn syrup you can develop
a very severe B3 deficiency because
there is virtually no B3 in corn so if
you eat a lot of it you become deficient
that nutrient and you start getting
dermatitis but it'll show up in this
symmetrical pattern of like your feet or
your lower legs or your hands all right
number 11. let's say a person has a red
swollen glassy tongue okay that is a B12
deficiency now again there's other
factors with B12 like you can have a
genetic mutation creating a problem with
B12 you can have a problem with your
stomach you can have a lack of
hydrochloric acid you can have an issue
with your small intestine you just don't
eat animal products because you can only
get B12 from animal products all right
number 12 numb or burning feet there's a
B1 deficiency usually coming from either
a high carbohydrate diet or the person's
a diabetic and this extra sugar is
depleting B1 and then your body can't
make something called myelin that
surrounds the nerves and you start
getting weird neurological symptoms on
the bottom of your foot it could be
numbness like tingling burning or pain
that is a B1 an efficiency what you need
to do is take a powerful form of B1 in a
fat soluble form called benphotamine and
that will get rid of that symptom and
then you'd have to change the diet as
well all right 13. if your eyes start
Crossing it's not being controlled by
the muscle and you may see this more in
younger children but it can also occur
with someone who drinks a lot of alcohol
or eats a lot of junk food because this
is another an example of a B1 deficiency
now if you like this video and you'd
like to learn more about nutritional
deficiencies I created a very popular
video entitled 23 signs of your body is
deficient in nutrients and I put that up
right here check it out